because if the distraction
is related to the language
then that's different hi
steve kaufman here and today i want to
talk about distractions and how we deal
with distractions
we live in an age where there are lots
of distractions
the multiplicity of media
has made it easy to be distracted from
[Music]
whatever task we are engaged with
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast surface please leave a comment
so
it's very easy i mean i do a lot of my
studying on the ipad
uh right now in fact i'm going through
some material from a
podcast
in persian called b-plus
where he provides sort of concise
reviews of books a lot of self-help
books one of which was deep work
by cal newport and the other one was
focused by a gentleman called goldman
and this is kind of what triggered this
idea in my mind of of how do we cope
with distractions so
i think when i sit there now going
through these in persian i've listened
to them and then i read the read them
and i look up words and it's
tremendously tempting
to just check my twitter feed and see
what's happened what's the latest news
is from ukraine or or to check my email
or check uh
all of a sudden there's a message from
someone
and so how do i deal with this
now
to the extent that
you know
i understand the deep work book
uh
a lot of the advice given there is is
pretty standard like
set certain times of the day aside for
doing certain things set yourself goals
deadlines
uh but one of the more interesting
concepts there
is the idea that
if it's if it's um kind of rewarding to
go and
see what sort of message has come in or
check your twitter feed
then every time you do that you are
rewarding yourself and therefore
building up a habit
of checking your twitter feed instead of
staying with the task of reading here in
persian and looking up words and and so
forth
so
you have to train yourself so the more
you can resist
the temptation so if this is a
10 minute
audio
lesson with a corresponding
number of pages of text that i have to
read through and look up words and
maybe i'm reading it for the third or
fourth or fifth time so i'm again
going over yellow words that i don't yet
know
uh if i'm able to stay with it and
perhaps a 10 minute audio file will take
me 30 minutes to go through
if i do manage to stay on task for 30
minutes whenever i do that
i feel that i've achieved something
the brain is rewarded according to
newport if i understand him in persian
the translation
um
then i'm training my brain just as we
train a muscle
uh
if you do certain things and repeat
certain activities you'll build up that
strength so similarly every time i
succumb to the temptation to look up my
twitter feed i'm weakening my brain when
i resist that for 30 minutes then i'm
strengthening my brain i think that's an
interesting concept because of course
you want to build up habits not only
language habits but study habits now
another thing is one of the things about
being distracted is and and sort of
being focused
i think
i like to make a distinction between
being distracted by things that don't
relate to the language you're learning
because if the distraction
is related to the language
then that's different because i think
one of the concepts in goldman's book
about
focus
is that that
you know
to some extent we should be open to new
ideas open to new stimulus and not
constantly responding to the sort of
if i understand the book again via the
persian the sort of more basic
instincts of ours that make us afraid of
this or nervous about that or want to
know about this and so that keeps us in
a sort of uh established routine
in a way we should be more open to new
things so
the distractions might be quite positive
for example if my wife is watching a
netflix series in egyptian which she was
doing a couple of weeks ago that's a
distraction and all of a sudden wow i
want to do more egyptian arabic arabic
in other words the distraction can be a
source of stimulus
and i think when we're we're language
learning
we're kind of uh
you know vagabonds we want to wander
around sample some of this sample some
of that
it's not like we sort of sit down and
okay for the next hour i'm gonna try to
nail this
vocabulary list
that's not very effective if we allow
ourselves to be distracted a bit
that can bring a lot of reward and maybe
makes our brains more open because after
all when we're learning a language we're
trying to get this new thing this new
way of seeing things of expressing
things
into our brain
and i think we need to be flexible for
that to happen we need to be
open to new ways of saying things and
this sort of flexibility in our attitude
i think is a big part of what makes some
people better language learners than
others so it may just be and i have no
you know research to just to support
this but it may be that a certain degree
of openness
um ability to willingness to be
distracted
willingness to enjoy the distraction
um
can be beneficial
while at the same time
if that is a distraction that takes you
away from the language learning task
itself then that's not a good thing and
so in that sense for example i often
feel that you know if i could read
better in arabic or persian i would love
to read actual paper books because then
there's even less distraction
less likelihood of going to my twitter
feed
and i found that uh say for czech or for
even for polish
uh or even russian ukrainian where i can
read those languages more easily
than reading in a paper book is again a
way of getting more deeply into the
language whereas reading on my ipad and
looking up words
and i'm listening to text to speech
those are kind of distractions from
the actual task of absorbing the content
and of course when we read and when we
absorb the content we are getting our
brains used to the language so
i i guess what i'm saying is that you
have to have a strategy which allows you
to be distracted
uh when you are good enough to read
paper books i definitely recommend doing
so
on the other hand
if as in the case of my arabic and
persian they're just so many words that
i don't really quite know how to
pronounce and i really don't know the
meaning of them
that is simply too frustrating to read a
paper book so i read on my ipad but my
objective eventually is to be able to
read
you know paper material in those
languages
so leave yourself open-minded
to distractions
but try to suppress those distractions
that take you away from the language
entirely
and doing that you can develop some good
habits
just like muscles which will make you
effective a more effective language
learner
that is all based on the distraction of
me reading these
persian language summaries of these
two english language books
again i throw this out there as a
distraction as a stimulus
ideas and you can make of this whatever
you want thank you for listening bye for
now